you know something spill it the Toronto
International Film Festival is underway
and since we know it's a must stop for
Oscar contenders let's talk about which
films are currently ruling TIFF right
now on the ketchup for starters critics
are loving writer and director Rian
Johnson's knives out which is his follow
up to 2017 certified fresh Star Wars the
last Jedi early reviews have this murder
mystery at 100% on the tomato meter and
it's been backed up by statements like
this juicy comedy thriller is a treat
from start to finish from Hollywood
Reporter's David Rooney and he's not
just talking chicken what is this CSI
KFC but it's not all that surprising
because the cast is stacked with stars
like Chris Evans Jamie Lee Curtis Daniel
Craig alongside Oscar nominees Toni
Collette Michael Shannon and Christopher
Plummer and luckily according to
Business Insider's Jason gracio Johnson
moulds a story where all these actors
get their time to shine I mean the sheer
fact that James Bond and Captain America
are in a movie together should be enough
reason to be excited right critics also
seem to feel that Johnson's take on a
classic whodunit is one no one's ever
really done before Brian toal Eriko from
Roger Ebert calm said it's a film that
works because of Johnson's palpable love
for the genre but he never allows the
film to become too meta or referential
and indie wires David Ehrlich wrote even
if you do somehow manage to piece the
whole thing together in advance there's
no way of predicting the joy of watching
it all unfold so I think it's safe to
assume it's not the butler in the study
with the candlestick in this one guys
I suspect foul play another film turning
heads at tip is a beautiful day in the
neighborhood starring the iconic Tom
Hanks as the iconic mr. Fred Rogers
earlier reviews have it near 100% on the
tomato meter and it's largely in part to
the nicest guy in Hollywood Tom
Hollywood Reporter's Todd McCarthy said
there's no question that Hanks is
perfect in the part with Steve Pond from
The Wrap adding it's hard to imagine
that is pitch perfect channeling of
Rogers is magnificent and slightly
unsettling calm won't put him in the
thick of a Supporting Actor race I mean
you had me at Tom Hanks in a cardigan
one film at TIFF that's actually getting
mixed reviews is Tyco whitey tees World
War Two satire Jojo rabbit critics took
to social media shortly after the film's
debut with positive words like max
Scoville who said the script is
incredible and how it perfectly balances
the drama and comedy unfolding but as
early reviews have come in the film is
currently brought in on the tomato meter
Indy wires Eric Kohn said yes ytt has
made a sugary fantasy in the most
unlikely places but in the process it
buries the awful truth and Benjamin Lee
from The Guardian added what ytt thinks
is shockingly audacious isn't back
frustratingly timid and the job of
playing Hitler for Laughs went to tyka
himself we actually caught up with him
at tip and he broke down the onset
dynamic between tyke of the director and
tyke of the actor nothing two of them
worked together very well they listened
to each other and I think there's just a
mutual respect but knives out children
rabbit and a beautiful day in the
neighborhood aren't the only things
people are buzzing about at tip JLo
who's never been nominated for an
Academy Award and has gone to the Oscars
more times than I've been to the dentist
it's finally getting Oscar buzz for her
performance and hustlers indieWIRE
skater bland said J Lo's performance is
quote genuinely deserving of awards
consideration and Eddie Murphy's return
in Dolomites is my name is off to a good
start with USA TODAY's Brian Truitt
staying Dolomites is like six SNL
personas in one and they're all a who
sounds like the club family dinner a
Nutty Professor Wow come on we're but
it's time to kick it over to you guys
now though which of these films are you
most excited to see and why are you here
for the foul-mouthed Chris Evan
two nights out do you think Jayla will
get her first Oscar nomination and
should they include tissues with your
ticket to a beautiful day in the
neighborhood
let us know all your thoughts and
feelings in the comment section and if
you liked this episode and you want to
see more hit that subscribe button and
click that Bell icon too as always
thanks for watching to catch up I'm
asked Prez and I'll see you guys next
time
you
[Music]